late night he's been on Comedy Central
Conan Last Comic Standing uh Colbert the
funny bone stage yeah now the funny run
stage he also has a Twitter account that
may be my new favorite that I follow
Johnny is cracking me up he's got a
great trophy uh joining on the couch
Mark Norman good to see you Mark hey
thanks for having me good to be here so
you do the rounds on late night TV shows
you did Conan five times five times yeah
the last one was Wednesday were you yeah
just on Wednesday then I flew here I
look Conan is one of my favorites but
he's on the other network now so I don't
I can't flip that high in the dial
sometimes I always forget about it so
you're on this week yeah it was on this
week and uh cone is the best because
I've done Fallon and Colbert and that's
Network that's CBS and NBC this is TBS
cable so you can really get a little bit
more I did a Muslim joke I did a Native
American joke I really went after it
yeah you can't do that on that Primetime
TV well let's start about or talk about
started eight years
yes ma'am about your friendship and that
kept going yeah yeah weird story I was
doing a comedy club I was green I was
wide-eyed bushy-tailed horrible comedian
and uh I was bombing but one joke worked
and during that one joke she happened to
walk through and she heard that one joke
she's like oh this guy's funny and even
though I was bombing so the whole thing
wasn't very good yeah one joke and then
she came in the green room she was like
Hey I'm Amy and I know who she was and
no one else did either and they're like
hey she's like you should open for me
and I was like sure and that was it and
your friends I mean you guys are pretty
close yeah buds yeah yeah so what's that
so seven years with Amy on on the road
uh Louis CK was you also toured with me
I used to over Louie too yeah yeah
that's where his Netflix special fun
fact put that out there yeah well what
was that like touring with it with Amy
though oh man it was great because I
watched her go from 25 people at the
Schomburg improv outside of Illinois and
then I watched her do the Charlie Sheen
roast then she got her own TV show and
she got the movie train wreck and then
right Madison Square Garden is it
amazing how fast that can happen insane
yeah insane no one I mean it was such a
whirlwind like before we know it we're
in the back of a Delta flight then
before I know it we're on a private jet
right crazy wow private jet yeah we
could use one of those we're about at
that level right I got some mean
barbecue I saw yeah you got some ribs I
do I was hoping you'd offer yes Jesus
you could have just had some but yeah
we'll get you some of those now funny
bone this weekend oh yeah have you been
ever been to Omaha before just with Amy
when we flew in flew out so I'm really
gonna soak it up I'll eat some meat and
see Warren Buffett and you know not see
any Jews just go to Warren's house just
go knock on the door Colleen has Warren
been out to the funny bone Colleen
we were talking about your Twitter feed
yeah how do you come up with your
Twitter are you just sitting around just
sitting on the toilet something pops in
you write it down you know what I like
about it is you're saying things that
everybody else thinks you think so yes I
do I could relate to it my favorite I
really like the Kickball comment oh yeah
when you're younger what was it it was
um
of kickball leagues are the original sad
way to meet people before online dating
yeah because it's true I have one of my
best friends met her husband playing
kickball I know a couple other couples
from blank
hilarious Twitter's great because Comics
think of all these funny things and they
don't always work on stage but you can
just put them out there in the world and
I have like 40 000 followers so somebody
will get it yeah I got all of them I
thought it was pretty funny so well
thank you but you know sometimes when
you put stuff out there you got to deal
with the the reaction from fans that
maybe don't take it as well maybe
negatively sure you know as a comic you
try different stuff so how do you deal
with those online trolls I don't even
think about it I just I favorite it and
I move on
you care the only way to give those
idiots power is to you know go up sorry
I'm sorry and apologize just go out you
know Screw you and get a life so you're
trying to watch my language here no
that's okay yeah kids watching Summer's
out oh yeah kids stay in school don't do
crack good message everyone yes we're
learning phases I want to hear a little
bit more about how you got started
you're from New Orleans yes correct from
New World born and raised of a comedy
town no so tell us how did you get to
New York always love comedy I always was
a fan as a kid but there's no Outlet in
New Orleans you can get up at a bar
maybe in a karaoke night or something so
uh my friend said I'm gonna move to New
York and I said I'll go with you and it
was a horrible trip I moved to New York
with 400 I got mugged three times in a
year landlord died of AIDS and I got bed
bugs
yeah all true how did you get I mean
what happened you got mug three times
well that was a pretty big booze bag
right and I would come home drunk you
know I was the the one white guy coming
home and in the rough neighborhood and I
was a Sitting Duck you know yeah I was
thinking after the second time you can
come to the conclusion that's probably
something you're doing wrong yeah it was
all my fault yeah
if no one had mugged me I've been like
guys you're missing out here like I was
that easy to mug I was fall asleep on
the train I woke up on the train once I
got his hand in my pocket are you
serious yeah yeah
why didn't we start with these stories
we'll bump the produce guy well we're
pretty well we would take a look
tonight two shows tonight two shows
tomorrow in the meantime before he does
that he's gonna be eating some ribs from
the Hog Wild barbecue this is vegan
right all right oh baby doll what a baby
doll baby back ribs well thank you so
much oh good they're good aren't they
very good yes
for having me appreciate it so